In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen."
The reading from the Sinaxadium, for July 2, on which we commemorate St. Stephen the
Great, Voyavod of Moldavia.
The Son of Bogdan II, Voyavod of Moldavia, in the years 1449-1451, and nephew of Alexander
the Good, 1400-1432.
St. Stephen ascended the throne of this principality in the year 1457, at a time when it was constantly
being threatened by the Magyars, Turks, and Todders.
During the first years of his reign, he waged victorious campaigns in Transylvania, repulsing
an attempted invasion by the King of Hungary in 1467, and drove Voyavod Rado, who had made
an alliance with the Turks out of Wallachia in 1471.
Three years later, he carried off a glorious victory against a Turkish army of 120,000, with
only 40,000 Christian soldiers.
When the Ottomans prepared a new offensive, he, who was referred to as the Athlete of Christ,
attempted to assemble a coalition of all the Christian princes, but he was not heated,
and the Moldavians had on their own to confront a gigantic Turkish army of 150,000 men, having
the Sultan himself at its head.
King overcome, Stephen fell back into a forest, and made as firm a resistance as his strength
would allow, and then took refuge in Poland, while the Turks pillaged his kingdom.
But the invaders, having withdrawn fairly quickly, he was able to retake a large portion of
his country, struggling not only against foreigners, but also against traitors at home.
During the last years of his reign, he gained successive victories over the Turks, Poles,
Magyars, and succeeded in preserving the integrity of the Orthodox kingdom of Moldavia.
A man of faith, and great valor, the Holy Prince did not put his trust in his own strength,
but in God, through the prayers of his spiritual father, St. Daniel the Hessecast of Vodonets.
For 47 years, despite innumerable trials, he governed his people with wisdom,
exhorting them unceasingly to unity and moral integrity in order to confront the enemies of the faith.
Having made a vow to build a church or monastery for every victory he gained,
he triumphed by the power of the cross, and 44 churches and monasteries were able to be built,
not only in Moldavia, but also in other Romanian principalities, and on Mount Athos.
Buildings of exquisite taste that manifested the survival of Byzantium after Byzantium.
He made himself above all the defender of Orthodoxy, and in the letter that he addressed
to all the Christian governors to exhort them to unite against the Muslim threat,
he declared that he was ready to die in defense of the faith.
He himself fasted and prayed for the salvation of his people and gave unstinting alms,
especially in times of danger. He had such a sense of justice and Christian charity that he wrote the
following words to the apostate Boyar Miku, one of those responsible for the assassination of his father.
I have forgiven you and have banished all anger and hatred from my heart.
The thought of death being ever present in his spirit, St. Stephen counted earthly glory for little,
looking entirely towards the promises of the kingdom of heaven.
He fell asleep in peace on the 2nd of July, in the year 1504, after having exhorted his nobles to
remain united for the defense of the land and the good of the people. His funeral was held in the
presence of a great weeping crowd in the monastery of Putna, one of his principal foundations,
where ever since, a vigil lamp has burned above his tomb.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.